welcome back to las vegas now so what
better way to work off your thanksgiving
meal than with a turkey paddle the next
day well you can do exactly that at
evolution expeditions and here to tell
us all about the fun kayak experience is
sebastian solantai did i get your name
right that is exactly how it's said okay
great thank you so much for being here
sebastian thanks for inviting us so this
is the first time you guys are doing the
turkey paddle tell me all about it so
we're doing a 10k
post turkey paddle to kind of work down
the turkey right hopefully um we're
starting at the willow beach marina it's
about 45 minutes from the strip area
down to
down into arizona a bit it's part of the
lake mead national recreation area um
but we started at willow beach we'll
head up
5k check out some cool sides i mean the
volcanic rock in the air it's about 15
million years old so we have
a lot going on there 900 foot tall
rock spaces a couple cool different
cutouts of caves areas
and then
the i mean beautiful pristine ocean or
river that we have yeah i'm looking at
these pictures here and it's so amazing
that not too far of a drive from right
here in vegas you can get out there and
feel like you're on vacation somewhere
else
so if people hear that a 10k they might
sound a little intimidated is this for
all levels all ages what would you say
it's totally
for everybody we get a little bit of
everything but we like to call it more
of like a um
beginner or intermediate level kayak
tour our guides are really well at kind
of
not giving the guests more than than
they can that they can take on the tour
10k sounds like a lot um but especially
if like if we're in our tandem boats it
it's a breeze yeah well and after eating
all that turkey and pie and stuffing
you're gonna want a little workout and
would you say that you've seen a rise of
people being more excited even about
recreational activities and maybe
swapping out their shopping day for an
activity outdoors totally um that's one
of the reasons why we bring up this
opt-out side movement um rei started it
in 2015 and they when they paired with
the nps and we're just trying to kind of
carry that tradition to get folks away
from the traditional shopping and to get
outside disconnect for a little bit of
time and then hopefully want to get into
kayaking or just any outdoors activity
more yeah and it's a fun way to hang out
with family too so if people want to get
involved how do they get tickets give us
all the details um so you could either
evolutionexpeditions.com go to the
special events page we'll have
everything listed there or you can just
give us a call
as well
702-259-5292 there um our
our admins will be able to get you taken
care of we are we don't have a lot of
spots left our full day tour is already
booked so now we have our half day tour
with
a catered lunch on a private beach
available and then for the first handful
of um
future guests that call we'll get one of
these sweet um event t-shirts awesome
well thank you so much sebastian hey if
you think about having that second scoop
of stuffing then you can go paddle it
off and it's a win-win for everybody
carbs galore yeah all right thank you so
much